Dear fellow scholars.
This is two minute papers with Dr. [inaudible]. I have been yearning for while.
Transport paper, and goodness was I ecstatic when reading this one?
And by the end of the video, I hope you will be too.
And now we only have to go through just about 30 years of light transport
research. As some of, you know, if we immerse ourselves into the art of flight,
transport simulations,
we can use our computers to simulate millions and millions of light rays and
calculate how they get absorbed or scattered off of our objects in a virtual
scene. Initially,
we start out with a really noisy image and as we add more AEs,
the image gets clear and clear over time.
The time it takes for these images to clean up depends on the complexity of the
geometry and our material models, but it typically takes awhile.
This micro planet scene mostly contains vegetation, which are math objects.
These we also refer to as diffuse materials.
These typically convert very quickly as you see,
we get meaningful progress on the entirety of the image within the first two
minutes of the rendering process. And remember in light transport simulations,
noise is public enemy. Number one,
this used a technique called path tracing Les referred to it as the okay
technique. And now let's try to use path tracing this, okay.
Technique to render the stories in a glass enclosure.
This is the first two minutes of the rendering process,
and it does not look anything like the previous scene.
The previous one was looking pretty smooth after just two minutes.
Whereas here you see, this is indeed looking very grim.
We have lots of these fireflies,
which will take us up to a few days of computation time to clean up,
even if we have a modern, powerful machine. So why did this happen?
The reason for this is that there are tricky cases for specular light transport
that take many, many millions,
if not billions of light rays to compute properly specular here
means mirror like materials. Those can get tricky.
And the stories that has been enclosed in there is also not doing too well.
So this was past tracing the okay technique.
Now let's try a better technique called metropolis light transport.
This method is the result of a decade of research and is much better in dealing
with difficult scenes.
This particular variant is a proud Hungarian algorithm by a scientist called
trouble Kellerman and his colleagues at the technical university of Budapest.
For instance,
here's a snippet of our earlier paper on a similarly challenging scene.
This is how the okay path tracer did. And in the same amount of time,
this is what metropolis light transport the better technique could do.
This was a lot more efficient. So let's see how it does with the tourists.
Now that's unexpected.
This is indeed a notoriously scene to render,
even for metropolis light transport,
the better technique as you see the reflected light patterns that we also refer
to as caustics on the floor are much cleaner,
but the Taurus is still not giving up.
Let's jump another 15 years of light transport research and use a technique that
goes by the name manifold exploration. Let's call this the best technique.
Wow. Look at how beautifully it improves the image.
It is not only much cleaner, but also converges,
much more gracefully.
It doesn't go from a noisy image to a slightly less noisy image,
but almost immediately gives us a solid baseline and new cleaned
up paths also appear over time.
This technique is from 2012 and it truly is mind boggling how good it
is.
This technique is so difficult to understand and implement that to the best of
my knowledge,
the number of people who can and have implemented it properly is exactly
one.
And that one person is [inaudible] one of the best minds in the game and
believe it or not,
he wrote this method as a PhD student in light transport research.
And today as a professor at EPFs Switzerland,
he and his colleagues set out to create a technique that is as good as many fold
exploration, the best technique, but is much simpler.
Well, good luck with that. I thought when skimming through the paper,
let's see how it did. For instance,
we have some caustics at the bottom of a pool of water has expected lots of
Firefly noise with the okay, pass tracer, and now hold onto your papers.
And here is the new technique. Just look at that.
It can do so much better in the same amount of time.
Let's also have a look at this scene with lots and lots of specular micro
geometry, or in other words, lens.
This is also a nightmare to render with the okay, pass tracer.
We have lots of flickering from one frame to the next and here you see the
result with a new technique. Perfect.
So it is indeed possible to take the best technique many for exploration,
and re-imagine it in a way that ordinary humans can also implement huge
congratulations to the authors of this work that I think is a crown achievement
in large transport research. And that's why I was ecstatic.
When I first read through this incredible paper,
make sure to have a look at the paper and you will see how they borrowed a nice
little trick from a recent work in nuclear physics to tackle this problem.
The presentation of the paper and the talk video with the details is also
brilliant. And I urge you to have a look at it in the video description.
This whole thing got me so excited.
I was barely able to fall asleep for several days now,
what a time to be alive now, who I will look through some more results,
the paper,
if you feel a little stranded at home and are thinking that this light transport
thing is pretty cool.
I held a master level course on this topic at the technical university of
Vienna. Since I was always teaching it to a handful of motivated students,
I thought that the teachings shouldn't only be available for a privileged few
who can afford a college education,
but the teachings should be available for everyone free education for
everyone. That's what I want.
So the course is available free of charge for everyone, no strings attached.
So make sure to click in the video description to get started.
We write a full light simulation program from scratch and learn about physics,
the world around us.
And more also note that my former PhD advisor Mika femur is looking
to hire a postdoctoral researcher in this area,
which is an amazing opportunity to push this field forward.
The link is available in the video description.
This episode has been supported by Lambda GPU cloud.
If you're looking for inexpensive cloud GPU's for AI,
check out Lambda GPU cloud,
they recently launched Quadro RTX 6,000 RTX,
8,000 and V 100 instances and hold onto your papers
because Lambda GPU cloud can cost less than half of AWS
and Azure.
Plus they are the only cloud service with 48 gigabyte RTX eight thousands
joined researchers at organizations like Apple, MIT,
and Caltech in using Lambda cloud instances, workstations or servers,
make sure to go to Lambda labs.com/papers to sign up for one of their
amazing GPU instances today.
Our thanks to Lambda for their longstanding support and for helping us make
better videos for you. Thanks for watching and for your generous support.
And I'll see you next time.